como vienen advirtiendo los científicos
los irreversibles efectos del
calentamiento global se verán durante
milenios pero sus consecuencias ya son
evidentes en todo el mundo julio batió
el récord el mes más caluroso de la
historia una ola de calor que asfixia a
las naciones del hemisferio norte como
españa que este sábado registró casi 50
grados en algunas regiones las
temperaturas extremas se están agravando
los masivos incendios que asolan a
europa como los de grecia e italia que a
mayor temperatura a los que se llaman
las famosas tres tenor el tiempo la
temperatura y la falta de humedad pues
lo que hace es que provoca la formación
de incendios y si encima la tempera en
la velocidad del viento es muy elevada
esto impide que se sofoque en dicho el
incendio en turquía o rusia además de
los feroces incendios forestales las
lluvias torrenciales en algunas partes
de dichas naciones han provocado
inundaciones y derrumbes dejando decenas
de víctimas este sábado el mandatario
ruso instó a tomar medidas para paliar
las consecuencias de los cambios
climáticos extremos
todo esto demuestra una vez más lo
importante que es para nosotros tratar
profundamente sistemáticamente para el
futuro la agenda climática y
medioambiental en eeuu las llamas de dix
y el mayor incendio activo en california
siguen causando estragos en el estado un
mes después devastando más de 200.000
hectáreas y en asia los devastadores
efectos de las lluvias torrenciales no
dan tregua dejando decenas de muertos y
desaparecidos en japón india o china
unos fenómenos meteorológicos extremos
los que el ser humano deberá
acostumbrarse en los próximos años
puesto que serán cada vez más frecuentes
según advierten los expertos